[Music]
hello and welcome to the week in 60
minutes
brought to you by spectator tv and
broadcast on thursday 5th of may i'm
katie balls the spectator's deputy
political editor and your host this week
on this week's show
in the spectator's cover story this week
james forsyth writes that boris johnson
is planning a new brexit clash over the
northern ireland protocol we'll speak to
james and the former brexit minister
david frost
russia's may victory parade celebrating
victory over nazi germany in world war
ii is on monday
there's been speculation that putin
might use it to launch a mass
mobilization of the russian people or
expand their invasion into another
neighboring country
peter hitchens will be on the show with
mike martin
a draft supreme court opinion which
would overturn roe v wade the historic
judgment that gave nationwide abortion
rights to women in the united states was
leaked this week
if roe v wade is overturned what would
it mean for american politics i'll speak
to freddie gray
and finally sam leaf asked in a piece
for the spectator's website where the mp
should really have phones in the commons
chamber after tory mp neil parish
admitted to watching porn during a
debate
sam will be on to discuss this alongside
israel hardman
before we get going a very special thank
you to canaccord genuity wealth
management who is sponsoring the week in
60 minutes canaccord experienced wealth
planners and investment managers who go
above and beyond to offer you support
and guidance just visit candywealth.com
to find out more
and why not subscribe to our youtube
channel too
click the red subscribe button at the
bottom of the video and tap the bell
icon to make sure you never miss an
episode
first up james forsythe writes in this
week's cover piece that boris johnson is
looking to get the gang back together
for one last brexit bust up the prime
minister he says wants to tear up parts
of the brexit deal because of problems
betrayed between northern ireland and
the republic of ireland
and he may be willing to throw away the
whole agreement to do it
where's this going and how serious might
the fallout be
james our political editor joins me now
alongside lord frost the former brexit
minister
james
in your cover piece this week you write
about a plan the government has when it
comes to the queen's speech next week to
reopen the brexit debate can you tell us
more
yeah so in the queen's speech next week
the government will talk about the
importance of protecting the good friday
agreement
in its entirety and what this is code
for is a warning to the eu
that the uk is ultimately prepared to
legislate to override parts of the
northern ireland protocol to protect the
good friday agreement now the
government's argument is that there are
three strands for a good friday
agreement
and all three of them are in trouble
right now uh
the dup pulled out of the devolved uh
power sharing executive in february i
have been very clear that they won't go
back into it until their concerns about
the protocol have been addressed
there is no north-south ministerial
corporation at the moment and the dep's
whole issue with the protocol is that
they think that it it hinders east west
ties and so the government will say but
it is prepared to do this
ministers
are increasingly convinced that this
would be legal under international law
because they argue that they are they
are merely moving to protect the
pre-existing international agreement
good friday
and so that gives them legal cover to do
what they want now i mean the big
question here is whether it ever comes
to legislation or not uh this isn't the
first time that boris johnson has tried
to use domestic legislation to shift the
eu's negotiating position think back to
the internal market bill and i think
what the uk government is saying is to
the eu kind of you've got one last
chance to come to the table and move
beyond the kind of very technical
negotiation about the protocol to a more
uh a broader one about how it should
work and if you won't do that the uk is
prepared to take matters into its own
hands
david you obviously led on this and as
well as being the lead brexit negotiator
were in charge of the protocol before
leaving government what did you make on
hearing about this plan was that
something you're aware of uh was in the
making before you left
so
i think it is a sensible plan i think
the protocol
it was a delicately balanced instrument
created in very difficult circumstances
it hasn't had good handling since
we left the the eu and the transition
period
i think the good writing agreement is on
life support and now really and
i don't see that the government has got
some other any other choice other than
to
to act itself now i agree with james
that i think it would still be much
better if we could agree
a revised set of arrangements with the
eu and i i still find it slightly
surprising the eu won't do this when it
seems very obviously in the wider
interest so i think it's right if that's
the government's plan to give it another
go but they can't take very long about
it it really does have to be a kind of
ultimatum and uh if not i think the
government's got no other choice than
than to act uh it's obvious that
protocol has got to change or be
replaced the only question is how we get
there
james why are the talks going nowhere
you say in your cover piece that this
trust has brought a new approach to it
in terms of tone
um
perhaps being
softer in her approach and less
confrontational than her predecessor who
is also on in this conversation um but
yet that doesn't seem to be bringing any
new response from the eu whatsoever
yes
as one uh figure on the british side
said to me after liz trust took over the
atmosphere in the room keeps getting
better but we're not getting any further
forward
i i think the problem is that the the eu
the protocol was meant to do two things
it was meant to protect the good friday
agreement
and the integrity of a single market
i think frankly the problem is that for
most eu member states the protecting the
integrity of a single market
uh is is the more important of those two
priorities and that leads to some very
legalistic approaches to enforcement
that i i think are that go beyond what
is required for example we haven't had
the protocol fully enforced in the last
two years there have been grace periods
i don't think you could say that the
integrity of a single market has been
destroyed by those great spirits so why
not make them permanent that would be i
think a decent basis on which to start
a a new discussion
and
i i think the the the other issue is
what the eu worries about is not the
situation now where uk and eu
regulations are still pretty much
aligned but what happens in 10 20 years
time when there's been more divergence
you know could this uh this open border
on the island of ireland become a kind
of back door into a single market i
personally think that this risk has been
exaggerated as you've seen during the
grace periods you know we haven't seen
you know uh lots of goods
flowing into uh into the republic from
the north as you know
as contraband that that's not the case i
also think you look at things like for
example the fact that if the government
decided to remove that from uh domestic
energy bills you know that couldn't
apply in northern ireland because of the
protocol it's hard to think that
allowing people's home heating bills to
not have sales tax on them is a in
northern ireland is a threat to the
integrity of a single market dave what
do you make of liz truss's performance
so far
so i think she's done a good job i think
she's you know she's picked it up and
and basically pushed the same things
that i was pushing as far as i can see
and
obviously her style's been a bit
different to mine but um
in the end negotiations are not about
style or warm feelings they're about
interests and you have to be absolutely
clear about what your interests are and
be clear about what will work for you
and what won't and
the the brutal reality is that the eu
have never put anything on the table
that adequately responds to what we put
on the table as a reform proposal last
year they've tinkered around the edges
they've never really grappled with the
the complexity of the problems that have
now emerged and and everyone can can see
that and that's one of the reasons why
we're in the the current position of
course they can say what we have we hold
you agreed this stick to it but you have
to look at the real world and the real
world is that things are deteriorating
fast and
unfortunately the eu is not generally a
nimble negotiator they tend to take
positions and stick to it and that's
that's what we've seen that has got to
change and um
it is very difficult to push the eu into
changing positions one of the things
that you often have to do is raise the
stakes and
perhaps this is what
the government is trying to do with
these latest proposals
now we know the eu position is
effectively to say well it's you guys
who agree to this you signed this and we
don't want to retrospectively change
something which uh both sides agreed to
so james if if we go along with this
idea that he will not budge and the
government go through this plan what can
we expect in terms of the next steps and
potential retaliation
so i think the eu's plan is is is to say
very little off the queen's speech
i mean the eu's view is that you know
words in the queen's speech don't
necessarily amount to action and also
there is a view on the on the eu side
that you know that boris johnson would
like a fight with the eu right now
because of his domestic political
situation and so they're not going to
give him one
i think things change if the bill is
actually introduced into parliament i
think at that point the eu will
unfreeze the legal proceedings against
the uk for not having uh enforce the
protocol and i also think it will be
made clear that the uk will not be
allowed to join horizon the eu
scientific research program
i think if the bill was to then proceed
through parliament and become law
then i think the eu would uh you know eu
side want to say that there's a nuclear
option of directly targeting british
products you know tariffs on on
politically sensitive goods and the like
you know that would come into play now
i think that the question is you know
some on the british side think that in
the current geopolitical circumstances
there will be more voices than
previously kind of urging restraint on
the eu side saying look you know we
don't want to get into a trade war at
this moment in time uh given everything
that that is happening
uh on uh on
on in ukraine and that the closeness of
the links at the moment between uh the
uk and uh the eastern european countries
and the bolt david do you think we could
be heading to a full-blown trade war
well i i mean just for a moment on the
domestic policies of this i think that
there obviously is a brexit coalition
that has supported boris johnson taking
him to this place pushed through brexit
and so on within
the parliamentary party and beyond
i i don't think you can
necessarily extrapolate from that and
say that
boris johnson welcomes a massive
argument with the eu with all the risks
that go with it uh particularly when
it's over northern ireland i think it's
something that he feels he has to do
uh
we're pushed into a position where
there's there's no real alternative and
fundamentals like the sovereignty of the
the country are at stake i i don't think
it's um a political tactic i think it's
it's sort of something that's that's
fundamentally important so
i i do think that needs to be kept in in
mind as well and one of the things the
eu have often done is is misinterprets
as political tactics things which are
actually fundamental to the world view
and and things that we want to get done
on the question of retaliation is
obviously possible
um i think it would be
uh uh extraordinary if the eu were to
retaliate in a major way in uh
in the trade area while current events
are going on i think it would be a
massive weakening of of of the west
generally and
for that reason i don't think they're
they're going to i think we probably
will see some measures if if the
government pushes this through but but
honestly i i i wonder whether the heart
is going to be there in every member
state to to do this and and push through
when
britain is such a
leading player in the the coalition and
in a conflict that let's face it could
go on for some time yet
now james david just touched on the
political implications and obviously in
the case that this is not just uh you
know boris johnson doing it for his own
political safety but could you perhaps
explain to viewers why um there could be
some self-interest here um in terms of
what it means for boris johnson's
position i mean we're talking on
thursday ahead of the local election
results but given partygate and local
elections so you go for everyone expects
for the prime minister to be in for a
bumpy few weeks so is the idea that this
could play to his right flank
look there are certainly brexitory mps
who are frustrated with boris johnson
but they stay their hand against him
because they say look we don't think
that any of his uh potential successors
would be prepared to see this issue
through to take the risks that are
involved in this in this kind of
brinksmanship so i i think there is that
there is there is uh i'm not saying it
is the driving factor but there there is
clearly an an element of domestic uh
politics in domestic party politics
party management
involved here too i think the biggest
thing is that
it is very hard to see if not impossible
how you can get the power sharing
executive in northern ireland up and
running without changes to the protocol
um but i think that i think i think that
you can see though that boris johnson
politically has always been at his
strongest when he has managed to kind of
rally the forces of leave to him both
within and without the tory party and
just on that james then i'll come to
david on this uh before we talk about
the legality and um those who will be
friends to the uk and those and those
who are not um if the government goes
ahead do you think that this would rally
uh brexit voters um you know not just
brexit mps because old belief it does
end up in this worst-case scenario where
you have to go ahead the eu retaliates
and you start to see significant uh
disruption to trade and lots of people
could start to think well brexit
actually isn't done despite the prime
minister telling us it was and it was
going to be
yeah i think this is the biggest risk
there are two big risks for borrowers
johnson first of all um frankly
voters in britain tend not to care that
much about northern ireland look at how
little discussion there was of the
protocol during the 2019 general
election campaign for example
i mean the second risk is back in 2019
the tories stood on you know stop the
arguing get brexit done people were fed
up with hearing about it they wanted it
over with done finished
i think it would be politically risky to
turn around to people and say actually
that thing we told you was done isn't
done because we've still got this
outstanding issue to deal with i mean
that there are clear political risks in
that
david do you agree with that i mean of
course you were a key player in um
getting boris johnson to the point where
he could promise brexit would be done
i mean there obviously are risks you
know if there's serious retaliation you
know who knows but um
there are also opportunities and i think
you know boris is at his strongest not
only when he's talking about brexit but
when he's articulating conservative
principles that the party believes in
and if you know the integrity of the
nation state the you know the integrity
of the nation on the international
sphere uh the right set rules in your
own country are not
fundamental conservative principles and
i don't know what is so i think there is
an appeal to this and rightly so uh that
kind of counterbalances the risk of of
retaliation i think a lot depends on how
it is done the care the strategic
thinking the ability to manage through
what will be a a complex period and of
course a lot depends on what else is
going on at the time
now if we're looking at the wider
geopolitics of this um ultimately james
um because the uk has been talking such
a long time about potentially triggering
article 16 shaking up the protocol um
those on the eu side like to say they've
had plenty of time to get their ducks in
a row and to speak to their allies and
one key player here is america if the uk
were to push ahead of this plan do you
think there would be a robust response
from the white house
i think the americans would be irritated
with the british if the british pressed
ahead with this uh i think on on two
grounds one
uh there is obviously a lot of
congressional opinion in the us
that uh view you know
that shares the british view but the
good friday agreement is more important
than the protocol but the problem for
the uk is you know they're basically
inclined to defer to dublin on whether
the good friday agreement is being
honoured or not and dublin's view of
what the good friday agreement and the
and its relationship to the protocol is
radically different from from london's
to put it mildly i think the second
point is
the white house worries about the
broader unity of the west and when you
speak to uh us figures one of the one of
the concerns that they express about
brexit is that the eu in the uk are
going to become like japan and south
korea two u.s allies who fall out at the
drop of a hat and they have to spend
huge amounts of time managing the
relationship and i think if the uk and
the eu were to start falling out again
over the protocol and i think the white
house would consider that the uk by
being the ones who were choosing to act
were the instigators of this there would
be a lot of irritation that you know at
this moment when the us is trying to uh
to ensure western unity you know the eu
and the uk to two vital parts of the
west are having this argument which is
distracting from that
david do you think there could also be
an idea building when it comes to the
perception of the uk on the world stage
that the uk doesn't follow law it breaks
international law um or do you think
that would be misguided
i i don't think there's any serious risk
of that i think anyone who looks at the
question can see that the protocol is a
very unusual uh beast created in in very
specific circumstances arguably we
weren't sovereign fully well we weren't
suffering fully when we when we agreed
it we were under all sorts of pressures
i think it um an attempt to redo the
protocol or put in place a better
balance i don't think tells you anything
about the the uk attitude to
international law more broadly we've
always been a strong supporter of the
the international rules-based system of
international institutions and i i don't
see that's that's going to change i dare
say the americans will be a bit
irritated if the government goes down
this road
that's life sometimes things the
americans do irritate us sometimes
things the europeans do do irritate us
but i think there is a wider
picture here that that has to be managed
i think that japan south korea and lg
only takes so far
um
the
the the difficulty that we have in uk eu
relationships is the protocol if we can
solve the protocol then there's
absolutely no reason why this
relationship can't be a lot better and
the last few months have shown the
potentialities and that's why it is so
frustrating that we can't we can't move
on but simply acquiescence and status
quo isn't enough we need to fix it and
fix it better
now i want to move on briefly to
domestic politics before we um end this
discussion which is first james just
briefly to viewers what is the time
scale then in terms of we expect in the
queen's speech next week and if the
government were to you know decide to
act on this um what are we looking at
so i think we'll get words in the
queen's speech about protecting the good
friday agreement in its entirety
i think there will then be kind of
one last
uk attempt to kind of get a negotiation
going i think if that
doesn't bear fruit then i think you'll
see the uk government saying that it is
prepared to legislate and then
introducing a bill and but i think all
the time trying to trying to say look
you know this bill is making it possible
for the dup to have talks about going
back into the power sharing executive
and also keep saying to the eu
we are prepared to to
to to talk to you and we'd rather do
this by negotiation than legislation i
think one of the really big questions is
how does how does the house of lords
respond to this bill and i think that
talking to uh to peers there are two key
tests first of all
how does it pass the commons if it
passes the commons with uh pretty much
unanimous conservative support the lords
will be more inclined to defer to the
elected house if there is a sizable tory
rebellion over it they will be less so
the second is what does the lords think
about whether this is legal under
international law
and i think this is going to become a
very big argument
do people accept the uk government
argument that this is
what i think will be the uk government
argument which is this will be legal
this is legal because the uk is moving
to protect the pre-existing
international agreement
rather than
just unilaterally ripping up an
agreement because it chooses to they
will argue that they are doing so to
protect a pre-existing agreement that
has precedence
if that argument convinces the lords
then i think the bill could well get
through the laws if it doesn't and the
government ends up having to parliament
act it that is going to add at least a
year to the process and i think that
becomes much more um
risky for the government because it a
takes the bill much closer up to the
next general election
and also you know there is a there is a
greater chance that uh the eu has more
time to uh create a common position and
there's also a chance that the
geopolitical environment could change
again and the eu could feel much more
comfortable threatening to kind of rip
up the entire tca
now we are speaking on thursday and
effectively we won't know much about the
local election results until early
tomorrow morning
and so we are limited in what we can say
but um just a few brief questions i
first wanted to say james
is this now a referendum on boris
johnson's leadership or has it become
more complicated what's the mood amongst
tory mps
so i i think that the these elections
are sufficiently patchy in england and
particularly in in in tory hell parts of
england
but it isn't going to tell us
that much about the wider domestic
political scene i i also think that the
tories have done a very good job of
getting their expectation management in
early if you talk to tory mps this idea
that kind of eight the loss of 800 seats
would be par has got into the
bloodstream
while as if you look at some of the
election and analysis from stephen
fischer of oxford university he thinks a
loss of around you know
200 odd 250 odd seats would much be much
more like par so you could have a
situation where the tory party has a
very bad night but but it is not quite
as bad as tory mps think and so they are
they are more relaxed my instinct all
right we should say that we're saying
this without knowing the results is that
what these results are going to do is to
further the divines that are existing
within the tory parliamentary party
i suspect in the next few weeks that
anyone who's got the lib dems in second
place in their seat is going to be more
worried about boris johnson continuing
as leader while people who've got us
northern or midland seat with labor in
second place will be less concerned
about that and i think that one of the
one of boris johnson's advantages is
that it is hard to see the candidates
replace him who appeals to both flanks
of the new tory electoral coalition and
i think that that that i think so i
think we are probably in for a prologue
yeah this isn't going to break the
stasis in the tory party and
david you've been critical in the past
about the direction of this government i
wondered in recent weeks we have seen a
new number 10 team brought in new
advisors to the prime minister uh an
attempt i think to to move to the right
on various issues such as rwanda um
are you seeing an improvement
so i think the the ship has been steady
a bit with the new team and a little bit
of
red meat i i
used an analogy when i was writing in
something a few weeks ago of it being
like the mary rose still a bit top heavy
and still a bit vulnerable to sudden
maneuvers and i think that's that's
still true i think uh
we
we need to see a bit more conservative
philosophy
over the next few months and years if we
are to recover from
the midterm blues and you know i've said
what i've said on tax cuts on energy
policy and much besides and i think we
need to just get a bit closer to the
natural supporters on this and some of
these problems will start to disappear
and just finally david given we have you
here i can't help but resist to ask um
there are rumors of banned reports that
uh you could be lined up for the vacant
seat left by neil parish here to quit
the comments um could you be tempted
with a route to being an mp
well i thought i thought you might ask
her um look i only just left government
and i left it you know because i didn't
agree with with various things that are
that are being done and that's that's
still true there's a lot of speculation
around but i haven't really got anything
to say on this subject at the moment and
when i do i'm sure the spectator will be
the first to know
okay well we'll read books
thank you david thank you james
on monday russia will hold its annual
celebration of victory over nazi germany
there's been speculation in the media
that vladimir putin might use the
occasion to expand the war effort either
to enlist more troops or to perhaps even
invade moldova which neighbours ukraine
is this likely how much can we really
know what is the latest of russians
invasion into eastern ukraine
i'm joined now by peter hitchens a male
on sunday economist and dr mike martin a
research fellow at king's college
london's war studies department
mike peter thank you for joining us on
spectator tv today mike can we start
with you can you give us an update on
the russian offensive in the donbass
uh yeah it's fairly simple um the
russians have
uh dribbled troops into the east these
are the troops that they pulled out of
kiev and added to the troops they
already had in the east
the ukrainians have
in most areas retreated quite slowly but
used that retreat to attrit the russians
so the russians have lost quite a lot of
troops and in some areas the ukrainians
are us beginning to counter-attack and
as before with kiev they're focusing on
where they can cut through and attack
the russian supply lines
and peter in the media has been a big
focus on ukraine doing better than many
expected particularly if you look at the
uh the initial invasion when a lot of
people say you know ukraine will be
taken x many days but are we starting to
see signs in a way of russia digging in
and slowly making some progress well
i've been trying to track down these
claims that ukraine is going to be taken
in a few days and i have to say i've
been unable to find them
in fact i've always been in difficulty
with this
with this war invasion and not really
being able to know for certain what the
russian intentions are and it's plain
they've come off worse in some
in some important ways but on the other
hand we don't really know what the
objectives of this attack are i don't
myself think that the size of the army
deployed was anything like it big enough
to conquer the whole country or indeed
seize kiev so i i wait to see how it
will end up it may simply be
and i put this forward simply as a
theory that what we're dealing with is
sort of warfare which has existed in the
past which is basically protection
racket warfare where russia is saying
well if
if you're going to behave like this then
we'll wreck the joint i'm not sure that
we've we've ever really heard clearly
what their objectives are and so we
can't
claim that they haven't achieved them
with any great confidence also an awful
lot of the commentary on this board i
don't know where the information comes
from
we don't have a and in war you very
rarely have any accurate figures of
casualties or losses you never have had
you look at the reporting of the battle
of britain for instance the numbers of
planes down by either side
turn out on on on inspection many years
later to be completely fictional so i i
tend to just to say well i don't know
really what's what's going on military
here i'm not there i'm in no position to
know and i find a lot of the speculation
rather tedious
mike do you think we can have accurate
figures after we see russia picking up
figures and also the ukrainians i think
something has changed in the last five
years
uh
and that's the social media and the and
the penetration of the smartphone
and
well that does two things i mean it
floods us with data
um
and so it is very easy to be misled or
perhaps to focus on the wrong things
but
i think in in the hands of a skilled
analyst or someone who's able to discern
a pattern in that data
twitter
particularly
and twitter basically mirrors what you
see on other things like tik tok and so
on and so forth actually enables us to
derive
quite a good picture of what's going on
in fact i would argue that now
if you really want to know what's going
on in a conflict as it's unfolding the
best place to go for it is
twitter and try to follow some people
who've got who sit in that you know
objective analyst position as far as you
can rather than the mainstream media
because the mainstream media have got
correspondence in this city and that
city and they'll give us good pinpricks
about what's going on
but it's very hard to get a good
strategic view so actually i would argue
you know we saw this with afghanistan
last year and ukraine this year
the use of social media has totally
revolutionized our way to
the way that we track these wars in real
time
well i can't really honor i argue with
that but
it seems to me to reinforce my point
if if it's if it's being suggested that
we should get an idea of how the war is
going from social media then i would
return to my position we don't have a
clue what's happening no but peter it
wasn't interesting we don't know what
the objectives of what they have
actually the mod
the uk mod and and the us
dod
now
have branches who follow social media
because they found that that is a really
important
part of their real-time updating of the
situation so as well as satellites and
electronic intelligence and all the rest
of it they will also study i don't know
uploading those photos
i don't doubt it
but it doesn't change my view if i find
the commentary of the british ministry
of defense uh it's rather odd it's a bit
like the italian ministry of defense
offering daily briefings on the falcons
war in 1982.
now if we look at the government picture
in terms of trying to work out what's
going on in ukraine we've had a few
interventions recently from western
governments so we had liz truss's
mention house speech where she talked
about pushing russia out of the entirety
of ukraine and also you've had the in
the u.s joe biden promising more funds
mike do you think we're now heading to a
very long-term conflict if we're looking
at what uh western governments are
saying and what they're prepared to do
to fund it
so if we just take those two statements
at face value you know pushing the
russians out of ukraine and this large
amount of money from the americans um
actually i think that they've announced
those
those statements
for the very reason that they want to
bring the conflict to a swifter
conclusion than perhaps they might have
been
aiming to hitherto
um
actually the ukrainians for a long time
have had as their goal the idea of
pushing the russians out of
uh ukraine to its you know sovereignty
so it's pre-2014 borders it's actually
the west that's catching up with that
for a long time we spoke about
you know punishing russia or making sure
that russia loses for these sort of very
woolly strategic games
and i welcome uh
actually a bit more of a well-defined
strategic aim
for the west and i think that once
you've set that aim and then the
resources which is obviously the 33
billion never mind that most of that's
going to go to
western armaments firms
um
but that the setting of an aim plus
resources is is how you do strategy and
i think that actually that is what is
going to foreclose the war much quicker
and i i think we will see
within a few weeks we'll see things in
donbass
turning
uh and i think within a few months we'll
start to see
reverses elsewhere in the battlefield
liz trusses claim this is gonna last for
10 years i think it's completely wrong
peter what did you make of liz truster's
comments well i i'm afraid i i'm never
been entirely sure that liz trust knows
where ukraine is in fact she'd rather
demonstrate that she didn't on her final
trip to moscow
so her pronouncements on grand strategy
seem to me to be open to some question
at any time uh productions on anything
seem to be to be able to question at any
time so i'll leave that to one side but
i do think there's a strong suggestion
here
that the there is a desire if i were
directing a western strategy then i
would definitely be aiming to maintain
an almost indefinite proxy war
in which uh ukraine continues to be the
the seat of battle uh aided in many many
in various ways by the western countries
short of actual open
uh uniformed intervention in a way which
will do serious economic political and
military damage
to russia in such a way that it will be
deterred
for the foreseeable future from any
similar action and quite possibly that
if
it fails badly enough uh you you'll
achieve regime change i mean i'm not
directing that strategy these aren't my
desires i don't none of these things are
things i want but putting myself in the
position of those
who who have got us where we are that's
what i think i would be thinking in
terms of what what do you have to lose
by it uh the the only dangers come if
the war widens out of ukraine and if the
if other nations and
nato nations become directly involved in
such a way that russia can't ignore it
anymore and if russia can't ignore it
anymore
then
russia may start taking actions beyond
the limits of ukraine and then the the
terrible possibility of a widened war
going
out into the rest of eastern europe even
further than that are there so
but
as long as you keep it at this level of
just constantly driving uh a a
a confrontation which russia can cannot
win but probably won't
in the foreseeable future lose either is
going to be very damaging to russia and
not particularly damaging to the western
side a poor old ukraine in the middle of
course has a terrible time of it yeah so
if you're if your real concern is about
ukraine then this is an immensely
cynical and unpleasant way of proceeding
but is the real concern of the western
paris ukraine
mike can you talk us through the
relevance of the may victory parade
so may the 9th is when russia and before
that the soviet union celebrates victory
over nazi germany uh in in europe we
celebrate it a day earlier
um and every year there's
i i can't really overstate the
importance of the defeat of nazi germany
in the
in the mindset the mythology if you like
of of russia and the soviet union a bit
like the battle of britain and you know
their finest hour that kind of stuff for
the brits
um every year they have a parade
of military equipment um through moscow
and so there's a lot of speculation
about
uh well firstly
during the whole of april we had a lot
of speculation about whether
putin was ordering his generals to
achieve some sort of
uh victory by that point so he could
declare well done guy you know the sort
of mission accomplished we've done it
all well done our brave troops
um
we saw some evidence that that was was
the plan you know sort of commands being
solidified senior generals being pushed
to the front and so on and so forth you
know as peter said
whilst
we can look at maybe what's happening on
the battlefield it's super hard to work
out what's going on inside um putin's
head or you know inside the heads of
decision makers in russia
um and since then since it's become
clear that actually there isn't going to
be any discernible victory by
may the 9th in fact
possibly quite the opposite
um there's been more speculation about
whether
putin's going to announce some sort of
general mobilization your viewers will
recall that this has been defined as a
special military operation so far
uh
you know some way short of a general war
um and if a general war is declared then
supposedly putin has the option of a
more general mobilization of the
population and you know drafting of
people to enlarge the size of the army
that could fight in ukraine obviously
one of the problems they've had hitherto
as peter alluded to is they just simply
don't have enough troops for what the
things that they're trying to do
um i don't think they're going to do
that either because
mobilizing civilians is a long drawn-out
process and if you do it with any speed
which they would need to to have an
impact on this
war then you end up with quite low
quality troops i mean the troops they've
got it already are quite low quality but
mobilized civilians poorly trained with
with you know second-hand equipment
aren't aren't going to be that effective
so i don't think
that he's going to do that either so
what we're left with is a may the 9th
parade with a question mark over it
they're probably not going to announce a
victory because they can't they're not
going to announce withdrawal because
that would be damaging to putin's
personal political position
they're probably not going to announce a
general
mobilization they're probably not going
to announce war against nato because
that's you know as peter's alluded to
that's a bit of a disaster for russia so
perhaps they may just have
a may the ninth parade
with a nod to the brave soldiers and
some captured ukrainian equipment and
that's it
peter do you think there'll be any uh
significance to this or or are we uh
expecting something that probably won't
happen well i'm one of the last living
people i think who attended the old
soviet uh november the 7th revolution
day parade which this is replaced
uh and it is fundamentally a
pseudo-religious occasion rather than
the political one uh the
it's it's the legitimization
of whatever regime russia happens to
have
with the
by by attributing to it uh the victory
over hitler which by any measure is
quite a major national achievement and i
always find amusing when people in
britain say oh well the russians make
such a big fuss about the second world
war don't they they go on and on about
how they won it are they completely
unaware of how our own pseudo-religious
approach the second world war appears to
outsiders here
most people have begun to get over what
happened between 1939 1945 now but both
in fact russia and britain have a very
very strong view that this is a
legitimation of themselves as nations
and in russia's case
a legitimization of their of their
particular form of government that's
what it's about if i i have no idea what
political announcements they might or
might not make because i have no
conceivable way of knowing what goes on
in mr putin's mind and i think we should
all be very careful about about
predictions i think the idea that
somehow there was going to be a victory
that they could announce on may the 9th
was was it's brilliant piece of
speculation something you put in the
paper and put on television but it would
be very unwise it seems to me for
anybody knowing the speed at which this
kind of war moves to do such a thing and
modern wars is incredibly grindingly
slow if you if you try to take defended
positions it can take months if you
succeed at all the idea that any of this
is going to move rapidly that we're
going to get a kind of 1940 type
blitzkrieg war has always seemed to me
to be slightly far-fetched
this just doesn't happen anymore and the
conditions in which it could happen
long ago cease to exist so i just
wouldn't expect that but then again i
have no idea what's going to happen i
don't even know what's going to happen
this afternoon and i don't know what's
going to happen on may the 9th
i think they're sorry
can i just pick up on that on yeah i i i
totally agree with you peter we're not
going to see a blitzkrieg
uh the the idea of armored formations
duking it out they just don't have the
logistics to do that um what i think we
might see which is quite interesting
is
if the ukrainians are able to
successfully counter attack and carve up
some of the supply lines exactly like
they did in the battle for kiev which
let's be honest the russians lost that
battle
i think we have a possibility of
collapses of pockets of the russian
armed forces and that could potentially
snowball i mean we've got a pretty
poorly trained force with low morale
that could potentially snowball into a
wider collapse of the russian armed
forces in ukraine so i that could happen
quite quickly as a kind of psychological
tipping point a bit like in afghanistan
the government forces collapsed in a
weekend pretty much
um so i do i agree with you we're not
going to see a big tank battle but we
may see a psychological collapse of some
of the russian forces
i could i just respond to that by saying
that whenever the verb could is used you
could equally well insert the words
could not
with exactly the same
exactly the same power and effect
maybe he will maybe won't i don't know
sure
time will tell
thank you peter thank you mike
a draft supreme court opinion was leaked
earlier this week which should appear to
overturn the historic case of roe versus
wade a case that gave nationwide
abortion rights to women in america
joe biden has since said that he wants
to bring in domestic legislation to
codify the 1973 case into federal law
how significant is this and how doable
i'm joined now by freddie gray the
spectator's deputy editor
freddie thanks for joining today you
wrote in a piece for the spectator said
that abortion is a nuclear bomb of an
issue and it just went off can you
update us on this week's events
well uh i think this is a
a very very big story um
partly because of the the way the story
came about itself it was a leak
from uh the supreme court which is
unprecedented a draft opinion has never
been
leaked like this before and so it's
quite a serious business in america the
the supreme court is an extremely
important even sort of sacred in some
quarters institution in america and for
there to be a leak like this is a major
major story
um particularly as it triggers and the
person who leaked it knew exactly that
it would trigger
a political firestorm because abortion
is still a very divisive issue
in america
and
i think even people who support roe v
wade the supreme court decision that
this draft opinion
uh apparently will overturn
uh except that it's a sort of grubby
legal compromise it doesn't quite hand
uh stand up constitutionally
um it's never quite worked as a legal
argument
and therefore uh in this document
justice alito a conservative supreme
court justice
is saying it's time to hand it back
to the electric elected representatives
therefore hand it back to politicians to
decide whether they want to legislate
create a federal law for abortion or not
or whether it should be state by state
which is what a lot of americans think
it should be this is as we've seen
already with the protests uh an
extremely incendiary issue
um and if you think that america is sort
of riven by culture wars as it is uh
abortion in a way is the original
cultural war it's the it's the it's the
subject that really started tearing
america apart in the 70s
and how does this play out next freddie
because ultimately this is not a final
judgment there's some way to go but
there's also
votes before we get there and joe biden
has already made this almost a
campaigning issue promising to take
action on a political level um
a what does that mean politically into
can he really do that is that feasible
well politically i think it's very
interesting it's obviously an
opportunity for the democrats for all
the uh hysteria and the wailing and
gnashing of teeth that you're hearing in
the last 24 or so hours
um there there's clearly a lot of
democrats that spy a huge opportunity
here because
one of the issues that really rallies uh
the democratic base is abortion
and the idea that the the radical right
will take away women's rights
uh so you will hear quite a lot of
democrats um talking about this as we
approach the midterm midterm elections
in november because they've they're
facing a real drubbing and they think
this could be an issue that could sort
of be a mood changer for them and could
actually pull them back from the
political brink on the other hand
traditionally the democrats have always
tried to refute the idea that they are
the party of abortion because that's
quite a controversial thing to be
so will they sort of position themselves
as the party of abortion it looks like
they probably will but will they box
themselves into a corner in so doing and
then freddie if if joe biden ultimately
has some wins on this does he have the
numbers to actually bring in legislation
so that even if the
courts decide that they are going to
change the rules so states decide
abortion rules rather than being an
individual right for women um that
politicians will be able to overrule
that
i'm not sure he does it's a it's a very
tight senate
and the
thinking is that senator manchin and
senator collins
may be not in line with the rest of the
democratic party on this issue so he may
actually struggle to get it through any
legislation through
congress
it'll be interesting to see how that
plays out
um i suspect uh that there will be a lot
of intensive pressure on the supreme
court um to change the decision the
supreme court will probably hold firm
and in fact in the document they said uh
in the draft opinion elito says that
external pressures should not affect
their decision on this so i think it's
going to become a very intense issue
uh particularly if it's overturned in
the coming weeks
leading into the midterms
and just finally and if this ukraine go
ahead they do not change their mind in
this judgment if joe biden fails to have
the numbers to bring in a political
solution which as you say lots of people
quite skeptical about his ability to do
and this change is brought through what
does that mean could you just explain to
viewers in terms of
how how abortion rules would change but
ultimately states individually decide
the rules
well in theory and this is still theory
because lots of things could change
it would go it would default to states
rights so states would decide uh whether
they whether they allowed abortion and
state law would decide what the state of
abortion was which was the case before
roe v wade in 1973 so we go back to that
and obviously a lot of pro-choice
pro-abortion groups are saying
that this will lead to hundreds of
millions of women being denied basic
health care
but then on the other side of the
argument a lot of
americans feel that this is an issue
that could be decided by the states
because that's the way america was set
up
and do you think in that scenario we'd
potentially see a divide between the
southern states and uh those in the
north or was that a simple way of
looking at it
i suppose generally that the southern
states would tend to be more pro-life
but it's not quite that simple i think
states where you've got a large
christian population uh or a mormon
population
uh you you will see a more of a pro-life
bent towards the legislation
but yeah i suppose you could do a bit of
southern versus northern but i don't
think that quite applies the map's a bit
more complicated
more complicated always thank you
freddie thank you for joining us today
and
sam
finally
the spectator's literary editor writes
for the website this week that perhaps
mp shouldn't be allowed phones in the
house or commons chamber at all
this comes after the tory mp neil parish
admitted to watching pornography during
a debate
to make his case sam joins me now
alongside israel hardman the spectator's
assistant editor
sam isabel thank you for joining sam in
your weekend column for the spectator
you wrote you have some sympathy for
neil parish the mp who admitted to
watching porn in the chamber can you
tell us why
well i mean very qualified sympathy but
um
i sort of slightly did buy this
ridiculous sounding defense slightly
because it sounded so ridiculous you
think he would have thought of a more
sensible um
line of defense if it hadn't been true
that he was actually shopping for
tractors
um rather than looking for porn and
there is in fact as far as i can tell
online there's so there's come to be
some support for this view because
people discover there's a type of
tractor called the dominator
um and that this could have
led you by accident onto a pornographic
website um i sort of just about bought
that account of events i mean where i
when my sympathy for him ran out was the
fact he was shopping for tractors while
he was supposed to be in the house of
commons listening to a debate in the
first place um
and that's why i slightly thought that
the arguments about whether pornography
was or what was not a kind of great
social ill were to one side of the point
isabel did you feel that much sympathy
for neil parish when he choose to step
down
oh
not really no i'm i think
i mean he's clearly been very
unfortunate in his in his googling and i
think
parents of tractor-obsessed toddlers are
quaking in their boots about what they
might accidentally stumble across when
they think
you thought
i was looking for tractor ted on amazon
prime but um but there we go but
sam's point about
mps on their phones in the comments is
really important because actually
we ended up in a debate about whether it
was right to be watching porn or not
it's obviously not right to be watching
porn at work but there was a wider
debate about whether it was right to be
just sort of fiddling with your phone
looking at anything in the house of
problems you know would it have been
appropriate had he got bored and been
watching hey dougie no it wouldn't have
been uh would
having a whatsapp conversation with lots
of other conservative mps about how much
you hate boris johnson be appropriate
when there are speeches going on in the
house of commons i don't know i mean i
have to say that as a journalist i find
mps having their phones with them in the
house of commons very useful because i
go and sit in the press gallery see that
they're there and start texting them
to see what they think of the debate or
just catch up with it because i know
that they are at a loose end and at
least in the house of commons chamber
you can see what they're up to whereas
in
bill committees which are supposed to
scrutinize legislation line by line mps
often sit there and uh write out their
christmas cards and their researchers
are coming in and out with more um admin
things for them to do while they're
allegedly scrutinizing uh the laws that
are going to affect their constituents
so i don't think it's just an issue of a
lack of attention in the house of
commons chamber i think
mps are
not so much multitasking but ignoring
the official task in hand to do
something else because they have decided
possibly rightly that a lot of what they
are hearing uh in the commons chamber or
indeed in these bill committees is
pointless but israel just on that i mean
what are the valid reasons an mp might
have their phone in the chamber i mean
if we take a report and if we take away
even texting mps about how you're bored
um are there circumstances for example
at prime minister's questions you've
sent us had a case where news has broken
during the session and then mp has
picked on it up on it and managed to ask
a question in response to it
so is that a reason to would pps's have
it to
stay in the loop um can you see a work
reason
yeah i mean i think it's the same as
some of us having our phones with us
um in work meetings as well um politics
does move incredibly
fast uh but i think there is a
possibly uh
an honesty uh in what neil parish ended
up doing which was that he just couldn't
be bothered to listen because um a lot
of the debate in the chamber is
pointless i mean it's you know mp's
making speeches that they've been asked
to make by the whips rather than
what they actually believe in bill
committees uh no actual line-by-line
scrutiny takes place of the legislation
it's all a charade and uh we end up with
very poorly written laws um and i have
to say having been in the house comes
for more than a decade now quite rubbish
public speaking as well i can understand
why someone's attention might wander i
mean i would never
ever text an mp in the house of commons
saying i was bored
others might do that but um but i have
to say that the quality of parliamentary
debate is not good in this country sam
we just talked through some of the
reasons
an mp could be on their phone i think
some viewers may find more reasonable
than others did any of them pass your
test or would you still ban phones from
the chamber
well i i'm kind of mind to say we should
probably burn friends in the chamber
because also
you know i mean it's on the same
principle that you know in my children's
school
they're not allowed smartphones in class
because they know that phones present
temptation not just the temptation to
look at pornography but the temptation
to play candy crush i mean all of us
know that these things are
precisely psychologically engineered to
be more interesting than anything else
around us and i can see that maybe
there's an argument
you know that you can
do rapid rebuttal to speeches if you're
you know pps or whatever we'll send you
or your spad will send you a text saying
you know what boris has just said is a
pack of lies and he hears the chapter
and verse on it
but
i mean i think
hansard is designed to move that little
bit slower and
you know if if we're relying
on
you know real-time feeds of information
for that sort of rebuttal um
i think that's that's an encouragement
to politicians to be under prepared um
rather than sufficiently well prepared
for the speech in hand they should be on
top of that material and corrections can
should be and traditionally are made
you know by written replies and so forth
i mean as well we'll know the
mechanisms better than i do
but for that narrow advantage or that
narrow excuse you'd be opening the good
doors i think to an awful lot of
extracurricular tractor shopping that we
should be
stamping down on isabel you mentioned
that some of the debates can be a little
underwhelming when you're sat in the
press gallery um do you think if there
were no phones a greater focus could
actually improve it for everyone
no i think the problems are um more
systemic than whether or not people have
got their phones
with them i think there's a lack of
seriousness about legislation uh the
incentives in westminster um are not
with uh scrutinizing policies they are
with ensuring that you have a media
profile there with um
ensuring that you're climbing the greasy
pole and pleasing ministers uh with your
wonderful speeches about how great they
are rather than pointing out the obvious
design flaw in something that's going to
make some of your constituents homeless
for instance and uh that would be the
case and has been the case uh pre all of
us fiddling with our mobile phones the
whole time and will continue to be the
case
and i have to say actually i mean one of
the other things that really surprised a
lot of us was that
neil parish was able to stream anything
in the house of commons because the
reception and the wi-fi in there is is
pretty appalling and
it can actually be very difficult to do
anything quickly with your phone and
because your emails get held up and
often when you're covering prime
minister's questions it's very hard to
live tweet it because the reception is
so bad so uh so say things don't move
that quickly and
even even for those uh those of us who
want to use it well very heavily
pixelated kind of late 90s style
pornography maybe
and as well just finally um while we're
talking about neil parish uh if we move
away from phones in the chamber briefly
i mean we've had a few weeks now quite
tawdry headlines in terms of passminster
um do you get a sense things are
changing or are we back to the point
where you have a week of stories about
people behaving badly and actually the
procedures don't really change
i don't get the impression from this
latest row as you say that there is
going to be
a big culture shift in the correct way
we have ended up having the very tedious
debate once again about whether the bars
in westminster should be closed
or not and i mean there is a whole
separate debate to be had about
westminster's drinking problem but
that's not going to make any difference
or not very much difference in my view
to the way in which women are treated in
westminster
to the way in which complaints are
treated in westminster and
actually it's quite a useful distraction
for a lot of people to talk about
bars and talk about long hours rather
than to talk about um the sexism and
misogyny that we still see in
westminster that a lot of female
ministers and mps have been trying to
talk about this week
thank you isabel thank you sam
once again the spectator is delighted
that canaccord unity wealth management
is sponsoring the week in 60 minutes
canaccord will provide the expertise you
need to build your wealth of confidence
you can visit candywealth.com to find
out more
that's it for this week once again don't
forget to subscribe to the spectators
youtube channel just click the subscribe
button at the bottom of this video and
tap the bell icon so you never miss an
episode
thanks for watching and do join us again
next week
[Music]
you